[Music]
thank you
[Music]
one thing that you have to be willing to
do is you need to be willing to fail
because it's always about this process
of failure learning from the failure and
moving forward
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
were you comfortable with failure I
think that was one of my biggest hurdles
is that I was brought up
to perform perfectly whether that was
playing the violin or swimming
competitively but in that process I also
did learn that you had to try things
multiple times until you got it right
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
anybody watching an elite athlete who
faces death in that way thinks well
that's a death wish but on the contrary
the people doing that seem to me like
the ones who are living the most full I
couldn't have put it better that is
a big part of what I think is a
misperception around what these athletes
do and who they are and why they do it
you know it is to live
and to live fully
[Music]
it's nice to have something like this
where there's no pressure because I'm
not a professional server
[Music]
foreign
[Music]